i'm sorry
i have to try
sure you're ready for that mr whitman
Welcomeback everyone this is my full eternals black
knight in ebony blade video marvel just
released the movie on digital and they've
confirmed we're gonna see the ebony blade again
during marvel's blade movie with mahershala ali
that was the voice that you heard talking
to him at the end of that post-credits scene
also explain what other plans marvel has for kit
harington's black knight character and just the
history of the character in general if you're new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos there will be some connections with moon
knight later on too and i will be doing episode
videos when that premieres in march this year but
the eternals movie has a bunch of scenes setting
up the black knight but when we meet him for the
first time at the beginning of the film he hasn't
fully taken the mantle from the previous black
knight in his family who was his uncle he was
the evil black knight from the avengers comics
if you've read the black knight comics or the
black knights history in the avengers comics the
mantle of the black knight gets passed through
their family when each new person takes the ebony
blade but they have to physically touch it so in
the post-credits scene when mahershala ali's blade
character asked dane whitman are you sure you're
ready for that just as he's about to touch it
it was him literally about to take up the mantle
officially he would have become bound to the
blade and gained all of its powers but all the
negative side effects the curse of the ebony blade
that's the main reason why he was so hesitant to
touch the blade and why he was apologizing
saying i have to try i have to try i'm sorry
i have to try you can make all the game of thrones
jon snow jokes about the black knight knowing
nothing of the eternals till later in the movie
but at the beginning of the movie even before he
learns their secret before he learns what's really
going on with sersi he knew about the ebony blade
and the curse of his family the curse of the black
knight he works at the natural history museum with
sersi so by trade he's a historian and knows
his own family's history about the black knight
in fact at the end of the film he's about to tell
sersi his secret the secret of his family during
that ending scene before irish and the judge shows
up and takes her to the other eternals on earth
back to the world forge to judge their memories
remember when we talked about no more secrets
turns out my family history is complicated
that's what he meant when he said my family
has a complicated history kind of like your
eternal family has a complicated history
he's the descendant of the original black knight
who was named sir percy he lived during the time
of camelot was part of king arthur's court earlier
in the movie when the eternals first go back to
the domo their ship thena picks up one of the
swords that they've collected from their travels
across the centuries sprite asks her if it's
the ebony blade and then says no it's excalibur
is that the ebony blade excalibur
arthur always did have a crush on you as in
the actual excalibur given to king arthur by
merlin in the lady of the lake that confirms that
camelot was a real place in the mcu history king
arthur merlin the rest of the characters from
the king arthur mythology were all real people
in the mcu at one point the eternal said that
they lived in camelot during its rise and fall at
the beginning of the movie sersi even gives dane
whitman his family's ring with the falcon crest on
it that's what that red bird on it is she lies and
says that she found it on ebay but really she got
it from the original sir percy black knight after
he died and it's implied she just kept it with her
this whole time even though they imply makkari
is the eternal with the sticky fingers who just
steals stuff left and right most of the stuff in
the domo here most of their treasure trove they've
collected across history is stuff that makkari has
stolen but this means that the eternals knew the
original black knight sir percy and sersi knows
all of kit harington's secrets here with the
ebony blade she knows everything the whole time
it just doesn't tell him since they have that
whole non-interference rule thing going on across
history it also sounds like they allowed the fall
of camelot to happen and they just took excalibur
with them after king arthur died or makkari stole
it after he died merlin during that period
would have probably been the reigning sorcerer
supreme on earth in the comics they have a more
complicated way of explaining merlin because he
also shows up in present day as a spirit they say
that he's from avalon which is also a place from
the king arthur mythology but in the marvel
universe they say that avalon is a pocket
dimension outside the main marvel 616 universe
but in the mcu he's just a normal person like
doctor strange who trained in magic and became
sorcerer supreme of his day so the mcu version
of camelot king arthur all this mythology is just
a little bit simpler than the comic book version
the original black knight sir percy was a good
character he started out as king arthur's squire
merlin chose him to become the black knight merlin
created the ebony blade himself out of a meteorite
that had fallen to earth i know that makes
it sound kind of like vibranium the vibranium
meteorite that crashed to earth but the ebony
blade is not vibranium it's not adamantium either
it's a different alien metal with special
properties so when merlin gave him the
blade it was actually part of a very indiana
jones last crusade holy grail kind of test
like choose wisely amongst all these artifacts
that i've created merlin presents sir percy with a
bunch of different types of items created from the
same alien meteorite ore and sir percy chose the
ebony blade you have chosen wisely so there are
other ebony artifacts like there's an ebony crown
and ebony shield and ebony chalice maybe they'll
introduce those in the future black knight
projects inside the mcu maybe we'll just see the
ebony blade and they won't do the other stuff
but it's meant to be a relic type of item an item
that has very powerful magic bound to it the way
they explained that in the doctor strange movie
with the magical weapons like the staff of the
living tribunal the magic in the weapons or armor
is so powerful that it exacts a toll on the user
sometimes in the form of a curse as with the
ebony blade but it's not a literal curse if
we're talking about the time of camelot king
arthur like a witch or sorceress like morgana
in merlin did not curse the ebony blade the reason
why they call it a curse the curse of their family
is because of the way the blade corrupts the user
the more blood the blade spills the more bloodlust
fills the wielder until they lose control
and go into a berserker rage killing everyone
it slowly corrupts them over time which they
actually reference in the movie twice the first
time they reference it is after sersi learns about
the emergence from irish and the judge and the
celestials she calls dane whitman and tells him
you know now would be a good time to make good
with your uncle you always said you wanted to make
up with your uncle dang confucius call your uncle
my uncle you've always wanted
to make amends with him right
now's the time trust me implying that dane whitman
had been on bad terms with his uncle previously
and even though dane whitman wasn't telling her
the whole truth of the black knight the history
of his family the ebony blade we know that sersi
secretly knows everything about his family in the
curse she was there in camelot for the original
black knight so she knows all about it but they're
implying that kit harington's dane whitman had a
bad relationship with his uncle because his uncle
had already succumbed to the curse of the blade
he'd been corrupted by it turning him evil
and that's them paying off the comics version
of the character in the comics his uncle was an
avengers villain he fought iron man thor captain
america all of them the events of the post-credits
scene are also right out of the comics what
happened is that after his uncle died he bequeaths
his castle all of his possessions to dane whitman
and then when he goes to investigate the castle
he finds a secret room that contains the ebony
blade in the black knight's armor which is where
he learns the secret of his family for the first
time the way they changed this for the mcu just a
little bit is they explained that kit harington's
dane whitman knew about the ebony blade the black
knight history before his uncle died but in the
post-credits scene it's implied that his uncle
is dead and that's why he's got the blade now you
only pass the blade on to the next person in your
family when you're getting ready to die the second
time they reference the curse is during the actual
post-credit scene when he reads the inscription
carved inside the case that holds the ebony blade
moore's mihi lukram death is my reward that
was etched into the case by the original black
knight sir percy his ancestor during the
fall of camelot in the context of the mcu
what it means is that the blade will eventually
kill him lead to his death it will also cause him
to spill more people's blood like your reward for
wielding this blade will be the death of others
and your own death it brings only death the blade
has a whole bunch of really cool powers though
after he takes up the blade and is bound to it if
he leaves the blade somewhere special like if he
locks it up inside this case and puts it in the
basement of a castle somewhere he can teleport
himself to the blades location from anywhere on
the planet the mcu version of the black knight
armor probably just forms right out of the blade
itself kind of the way that moon knight's costume
manifests around him you just have to picture
kit harington's black knight picking the blade
up and then just summoning the armor from the
blade as long as any part of him is touching
the blade he can't be killed he can be injured but
he can't be killed so he's functionally immortal
and the blade will trap the souls of the people
he kills with it strengthening him that's also
connected to the bloodlust that fills him
like the more powerful he becomes the more
souls the blade consumes the more it corrupts
him that's what all the whispers coming off
the blade are when he's about to touch it those
are the dead people who were slain by the blade
it can block magical attacks like dr strange's
magical attacks it can cut through almost any
known substance although it is harder for
him to cut through adamantium and vibranium
he can also use the blade as a
sort of magical detection device
to find other powerful magical artifacts
so the big teaser here in the post-credits
scene with the mcu blade mahershal ali now
confirmed by the marvel people also is that
the next place we'll see black knight in the
ebony blade is in the blade movie next year
and the reason why blade knows about the ebony
blade like he understands his family's curse
is because he had a relationship with
dane whitman's uncle previous black knight
and they're probably going to establish that
the mcu black knights across history spent
most of their time fighting supernatural creatures
like vampires werewolves other magical creatures
so basically in the mcu we're going to be
getting kit harington black knight vampire hunter
i'm also hoping that they do a black knight disney
plus series for his character just to cover more
of the history of their family like more of kit
harington becoming black knight but also using
flashbacks to show us the original black knight
in camelot in other versions of the black knight
from across his family's history kevin feige
also implied that he'd cross over into avengers
5 when they get ready for that movie along with
sersi maybe another eternals character or two but
mostly sersi and black knight because they were
long time members of the avengers in the comics
marvel actually just did a new black knight series
last year called curse of the ebony blade so you
can tell they're rolling hard on his character
in the future the mcu also don't be surprised
if marvel puts him on another supernatural darker
mcu team up like defenders or midnight sons with
characters like blade ghost rider oscar isaac's
moon knight just a darker mcu team up in general
if you do have any other questions about the black
knight his history how they're going to use him
in the mcu just post them in the comments below
and i'll try to answer them i will be doing full
episode videos for moon night when it releases
in march this year you can click here for my full
moon night trailer video and click here for that
new eternals black knight deleted scene with kit
harington thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!